c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche au plus tôt macgyver
voulait guy lagache à poil guy lagache
una faro navarro nique les experts
ronnie que les experts
et moi je vais tagués tiens je vais te
dire un truc je vais était guère
[Rires]
bachelot alors ça va on le voir vous
voulez vous les nôtres bombe
c'est magnifique
les experts auraient tout fait dans ce
métier lagache
ah merde la datcha toile voilà bah ouais
j'ai pris le noir voilà ça le fait bien
bachelot tpr et ben voilà c'est fait
preuve et françois berléand et regarde
ça comme si c'était une grande offre la
balle à patrick chesnais je vous avais
fait nettoyés
merci on les retrouve demain à tous de
12 ans d'âge patrick chesnais et
prochain vergnaud bastide raritan coup
ce soir merci à toute l'équipe qui
charbon presse merci à vous et on se
retrouve bien sûr les mains donc vous
n'êtes pas bien explique moi quand même
avant dernière course devant 12 ans
d'âge oublier la jouer star si l'on
regarde la ville et chérie tu rentres
est libre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]